first starting with a little 1994
are there any shared traits or specific
reasons you picked certain shady ciders
to
feel hopeful that they could go on and
get out of town versus the ones that
have that doom and gloom attitude
[Laughter]
oh man i don't know i don't know if
there was like really kind of like a
firm decision of like this person
deserves it or this person doesn't
i think with dina dina really obviously
embodies this feeling of like i'm never
getting out
how am i going to get out and i think
that was exciting to be able to show
that like
she actually does feel invigorated and
kind of motivated
to to learn and to change her world by
her relationship with sam and by her
love with sam which is
was just challenging and not perfect in
any regard
um so yeah where did sam fall in that
range pre her move to sunnyvale was her
attitude you know i'm gonna get out and
seize the world or was she also
doom and gloom about what it means to be
a shady sider no i think sam
actually felt like she had a way out but
unfortunately sam's way out was kind of
by trying to be somewhere
someone else and so i think that like
the idea that she could just become this
kind of
image of a sunny veiler she could do
that she could fit that mold she played
the part
she looked the part but it was false
because it's not her being herself and
that's something that she kind of has to
learn and go through
over the course of the movies okay now
i'm taking that and i'm bringing it to
the
1666 of it all what was it like
pinpointing how much of a 94 or 78
character came through
in the same actor's 1666 character
um i mean i really made sense i think
that we got to see these characters from
the different movies back in 1666
because
it felt like we what we were trying to
do in 1666 was show
all of the ways that things went wrong
with
similar relationships or similar kind of
interactions and then
later on hopefully in the 70s and then
the 90s kind of have a chance to write
those wrongs
um so that was kind of the that was the
core kind of idea behind
using the actors over and over again and
you know there's little things like
characters that live
in 1666 die in the other movies or
characters that die in the earlier ones
live in this one
so there was like a whole kind of thing
of like history repeating itself and
again things writing right wrongs being
righted
was there any particular character that
that appears in multiple films that
maybe was a little more challenging to
to craft that through line for
well i mean i think that an interesting
one is actually jeremy who plays
peter in 94 kind of sam's like douchebag
boyfriend
and then he plays caleb in 1666 because
you know it was it was easier with the
ones that um
that we kind of like that we feel like
we understand and we're rooting for and
then we have these other guys who are
just like
there and we're kind of like why do you
exist there so he was challenging
um i really love kind of the dichotomy
between mad thomas
in 1666 and tommy in 1978 and mccabe
mccabe who plays both of those he shot
matt thomas first and he was so amazing
as mad thomas that i kind of was
inspired
um to to change a little bit of how his
character was um
was portrayed in the in the second movie
the nightwing killer
used to be masked very early
in 1978 and then mccabe was just so
amazing
that i was like why are we putting a
mask on you 20 pages in
let's like watch you be tommy let's
watch you
become this awful monster and then we'll
get to the mask at the end and so that
was really motivated by how amazing he
was
very very effective choice also in
78 you had a lot of brutal kill
sequences
leading up to this but i was very
curious about your choice
to sit on the like the stabby stabbiness
of it for so so long like it's very
effective
but i was like wow like you're really
going for it with this one
yeah i um i was okay so i shot that
movie last
that was the last movie in the three and
i was so
tired i was so tired by the end that i
was like
more blood more blush more violence
i'm not kidding it was just like the the
wardrobe the special effects people the
costume they would like
they would all come up to me and i'd be
like just more just make it more
and it was just like a real reflection
of where my soul was at the time
i feel like that serves the film quite
well totally it's so brutal
and awful and um it's i think it's
really good but but that was a lot to
have that had to do with it
yeah all right going to solomon now
actually more specifically sarah i was
wondering if if solomon hadn't killed
the widow
and taken the book and let's say sarah
was the one who found the book
do you think that she actually would
have went through it or would she have
found maybe a different way to get back
at the folks in the town
yeah i think that she i don't think she
would have ultimately gone through with
it i think that obviously we never got
to that point but i think that like
she was obviously motivated very much by
her love for
for hannah and trying to save her and
trying to find a way out and i think
that
her kind of kiana speech that she gives
us sarah where she's like
it doesn't matter if we're guilty or not
they think we are and that's all
like that's very real but i think that
she would have cont i think she has that
spirit of dina in her
of sarah and her she would have
continued to rage and fight even though
she's brought to the edge of kind of
like
am i going to make this deal am i not so
yeah i feel it watching it
and now obviously i've had even more
time to obsess over the opening credits
of 94 and the one that caught my eye
there was the humpty dumpty killer
like who is that and why did that
individual not appear in the film
i don't know i love the humpty dumpty
killer he was in the original script
like i put him in there and i kind of
had this like
really um interesting backstory that i
started thinking about about a guy that
um that was killing people and taking
their body parts and making new people
out of them like like sewing things
together of like
you know humpty dumpty putting things
back together again and then i just
didn't quite know like what era
it made sense for him to live in and
what it was and i was kind of like
secretly
there's a lot to have happen here maybe
we'll deal with this in another movie
like borderline having a laughing pit
because i'm a big old dum-dum who was
picturing a killer that just like pushed
people off wedges
meanwhile i'm like no he's like chopping
people up into bits and sewing them
together
i mean both kind of apply yes all right
before they kick me out i got one
question about the very very
end in the end credits like that fun
little scene where we see someone
grabbing the book
is that there because you have an idea
or is it kind of just like a fun little
thing to wrap the films up with oh no no
no we have ideas
we have ideas the right answer
yet again i cannot congratulate you
enough now i'm not just obsessed with 94
i'm obsessed with the entire trilogy
great
perry was so good to see you again i'm
so excited